Given that this disease,
its big problems in outcomes are in the elderly,
we might need to put some stimulants in to make it a more potent immune response.
So all of that work has to go on. That's what the clinical testing is.
Eventually you say, "Aha! Here's the vaccine we're going to use."
Now you test it in an efficacy trial.
And that is to see, does it work?
And at that point,
you then have a vaccine that you know works.
But there is a stage after that,
and that stage is, you've got to work out the manufacturing,
have it all worked out so that the regulators know
that you can really make this,
and that it's pure, it doesn't have any problems with it.
And during that period, and that's what we did in Ebola,
we were able to use those vaccines to help in outbreaks
under a clinical trial protocol while monitoring them and learning.
So there's a lot of steps there, and it's complicated,
and I've shortened it a little bit.
CA: But summarize the steps that they basically need to go through.
I heard probably an animal test,
and then --
SB: Well, for example, Moderna.
They went into humans at the same time they're doing animal testing.
We don't have a perfect animal model.
But normally it takes 10 to 15 years to do this,
and that's the compression you're trying to do here.
So the challenge is, we can compress all those different clinical trials.
The basic way you think about it is, preclinical studies, animals,
understanding it, purity, reproducibility.
Then you move into human studies.
You start off with a small number of healthy people.
You then work on the dosing, how much, how often.
Then you move into people at risk for the disease --
that might be in this case the elderly or people with other conditions --
and then eventually do an efficacy trial.
Now, one of the cool new things we can do today
is something called "adaptive trial design."
So rather than do these sequentially,
what you can begin to do is enroll people
and then, as you get the data you need,
you can just begin to bring in the next set of groups,
and by doing that, you can speed it up dramatically.
CA: When you say enroll people,
you mean enroll people who have their eyes wide open.
They have informed consent. I think that's the term.
SB: Absolutely.
CA: And they're willing to, I guess, take the risk
that this isn't a fully tested vaccine but it may well be efficacious,
and so that obviously can help a lot.
That's crucial to this, right?
SB: Absolutely. They are the unsung heroes of vaccinology,
because people go out, they volunteer to take a substance,
particularly early on, that don't know how it's going to react.
Is it going to make the disease worse? Make it better?
Is it going to protect them? Is it going to make them sick?
So you try to predict that if you can with animals,
but people do do that, and the informed consent says
not only you may have these side effects or these problems,
but also this vaccine may not work.
And so it's important for people to understand that,
because you don't want people to go and put themselves at high risk,
saying, "Oh, gee, I had a vaccine, and so I'm protected."
We don't know that until we get to the efficacy stage of trials.
CA: But Seth, even putting together all those dots,
what I've heard most people say
is that it is likely to take at least 18 months
before the world will have a vaccine available
at any kind of scale.
Is that time line right?
And can the world remotely afford 18 months on this?
SB: Well, I think, you know, I've given you many questions.
I could raise lots more questions.
So part of it's going to be luck:
How easy is this particular candidate vaccine going to be?
How lucky will we be in getting a good immune response?
Which approaches will work? Will they be scalable?
So I think there's lot of questions there.
The world will do everything they can to squeeze it down,
but I think that's the time line we're talking about.
And remember, it's 10 to 15 years usually.
In the case of Ebola, we did it in five years to a licensed product.
In this case, we are hoping to squeeze it down dramatically,
but there are many things we're going to have to go through,
and it's really about making sure that vaccine works and it is safe for use
in what ultimately may be billions of people.
CA: Whitney.
WPR: Hi. So we have lots of questions coming in, Seth.
One of them that's kind of related to this is, you know,
a lot of us right now are isolating,
and we're not building our exposure to this virus,
so how will that affect us in the long term?
Will this make us vulnerable to the virus until a vaccine is available?
SB: So that's a great question,
and, as you know,
we don't fully understand the epidemiology of this virus,
but there is some sense that there may be asymptomatics.
Do they get immune protection?
Are they afterwards resistant to infection?
We don't know that, but we do know that people do get sick,
including young people,
and that sickness can be quite severe.
Obviously, a lot of it is mild, but some of it is quite severe,
and then it gets more severe in the elderly.
So I wouldn't recommend that anybody go out
and intentionally try to get exposed to this virus now.
The whole idea of having isolation now
is to try to stop the chains of transmission,
protect health workers in hospitals,
with the idea being that if you can suppress it enough --
and Bill talked about this in his talk --
and later on have testing available,
you might be able to go back to somewhat of a normal life
and then watch for reintroduction of this virus.
Of course, at the end of the day,
we will probably need a vaccine to be able to completely control that,
but the experiment is going on,
in China ...
Japan has done an amazing job of controlling this
with slightly less severe interventions.
We've seen in Korea similar things.
So the hope would be that if we take it seriously,
we actually damp down the exposures and stop this epidemic now,
we'll be able to remove to some form of normalcy.
And we also may have drugs,
and drugs will change the dynamics as well,
because people will then know that they are able to get treatment as well.
WPR: Great. I'll be back later with other questions I'm seeing.
SB: Thanks, Whitney.
CA: Thanks, Whitney.
Thanks everyone watching. Keep those questions coming.
Seth, this time line, I've been puzzled about this,
because I get that there are so many things
that have to be checked out,
but I still worry
that the rules are not adapting rapidly enough
for the scale of the emergency.
I mean, my analogy would be: you're going about your lives,
and suddenly there's this emergency,
you see that there's this enemy force approaching you from the horizon
and coming your direction.
You don't, in that circumstance, spend a week trying to test all your guns
and make sure they're operating absolutely safely and in the right way.
You galvanize and you do take some additional risk
for the sake of avoiding the bigger risk.
Is that thinking prevalent right now?
Are there people trying to make those kinds of trade-offs?
How should we think about that?
Or do you really believe that the community is galvanizing
and moving forward as fast as it humanly can
and appropriately balancing the two risks?
SB: I think we're seeing heroics in moving forward here.
Obviously, you're right, and the reason we talk about going from 10 to 15 years
down to something like 18 months
is about squeezing those steps as much as possible.
The regulators in the Ebola experience were really fabulous.
They worked with us
and tried to keep any bureaucratic delays down to the smallest amount possible.
And I think that's what's going to be important here,
is we have to look at every single step
and say, "Is it critical?"
But you do need to answer a lot of these questions.
For example, if you have a vaccine that works in healthy people,
it very well may not give an immune response to the elderly.
We may need to change that vaccine to make it work there.
It may not work in young children.
So you need a certain amount of studies done.
Of course, if you work in areas that have big outbreaks,
you're able to also enroll more quickly
and follow people more quickly.
That's one of the reasons we'll have to think about this globally,
because we don't know in 12 to 18 months,
or even six to 18 months, if we're really lucky,
where the epidemic will be raging and where we want to do the clinical trials.
We should be prepared to do them wherever in the world it's possible,
and also do some in different types of countries.
Developing countries may have different immune responses
than in wealthy countries.
CA: What alarms me a bit
is that on the models I've looked at,
with the possible exception of what happened in China and Japan,
by distancing, we can bend the curve, we can reduce infection.
But as soon as you go back to normal,
there's this huge risk of a massive resurge,
and until the vaccine comes along, it feels like your choices are:
one, sort of recklessly expose the whole population to the bug
and develop some kind of herd immunity,
or try and do this scary dance of really cramping down on the economy
and all the risks that are associated with that,
and risking, if you lift the lid on that, risking these really dangerous
second surges.
So is that the right way to think about it?
There's a scenario where, until this happens,
and if it's 18 months,
that's an incredibly long time for the world to be
in that sort of dangerous, scary dance.
SB: Well, I think the issue here is that is a little bit the way to think of it,
but the experiment is going on now.
China is now releasing its controls, and we will see what happens there.
We'll see where they have to clamp back down
and what's going to happen,
and we'll get a good idea of what that's like.
Right now, in many countries, we're still in the upscale period
when we're seeing lots of cases.
And so we have to break that transmission first
before we can have that conversation.
I'm the first person that would like a vaccine to occur quicker,
and, of course, my job is to underpromise and overdeliver,
not the other way around.
And I think we have to be careful not to think about,
"Oh, we can just have a vaccine in a couple of months."
It may be that we're lucky. It may be that it's easy to do.
It may be the first few candidates will show promise,
we get efficacy, we can scale those up for at least some limited use
while it's being worked out.
But a lot of things have to fall in place for that to happen.
And that's why we want to have an organized, global effort
to absolutely incentivize the best possible chance
for that to happen in the fastest way.
CA: There's some kind of debate out there
about whether there might be way, way more cases,
mild cases, basically zero-symptom cases of coronavirus out there
that may have granted more people immunity than we know.
Is that a credible suggestion?
More cases and much lower fatality rate than we know,
because so many of the cases could be invisible?
SB: You know, Mayor Bloomberg used to have a saying that I loved.
He said, "In God we trust. Everybody else, bring data."
And I think the answer here is we haven't done enough testing to know,
and we started out with PCR tests to look for virus,
and therefore, if you had recovered, didn't have the virus anymore,
we weren't able to pick it up.
Now there are beginning to be antibody tests
to look to see if you've been exposed
and don't have the virus now but have an immune response to it.
Once we have those tests operating at scale,
we'll be able to understand what the epidemiology is
and what's happening,
and then we'll be in a much better place to understand how this is playing out.
Also, I mean, even the question:
We don't see a lot of cases in children --
is that because the children get infected but they don't get symptoms,
and therefore they might be potential spreaders?
Or, is it because those children don't get it at all?
CA: So tell us, Seth, about this call that you issued yesterday.
I mean, you've said that scientists are behaving heroically.
But you've called for something more here
from both scientists, companies, governments.
Tell us what your call is.
SB: So, first of all, I believe that, given the situation here,
this is not the time to just let the normal system work,
as we've talked about.
I think we have to think about vaccines as a global public good.
And what that means is that initially, it ought to be public sector financed.
Obviously, if others want to contribute resources,
I believe they should, fine.
But we want to make sure the best approaches come,
and it doesn't matter where they come from in the world.
We want to make sure if the best approach is in China or Japan or in South Korea
or in the US, wherever it comes from, whatever company has the ideas,
get them on the table.
Then we want a process to say, realistically,
how are these being compared?
How do we decide which ones are most likely to succeed?
And then, as I explained, some diversity in taking those risks.
Maybe some new technology, some old technologies to drive forward.
Once that happens, then, to try to get clinical trials
to drive forward as quickly as possible.
Now, the delay here is actually likely to be in manufacturing,
because we might want billions and billions of doses,
so how do we then begin to invest, at risk, in manufacturing plants?
If it's a big company, they may have adequate manufacturing,
but we may want to work with contract manufacturers,
other companies, or even build plants or use new technologies,
modular technologies to do this.
And then, of course, at the end is going to be the process
of getting the vaccine out to all those who need it,
and that's going to need to be dependent upon the risk at that time.
CA: Help me understand this better, Seth,
because right now, it feels like there's this huge effort going on,
but companies are operating, in a way, competitively with each other.
To an extent, countries are operating competitively with each other.
Are you saying that what the world needs is some kind of widely supported
global -- I don't know -- vaccine czar
that is pulling together different efforts,
coordinating, encouraging everyone to work together for the common good,
and trying to get agreement on these big decisions
like what are the smart few candidates to get behind,
rather than this confusing explosion?
And then, how do we coordinate manufacturing, etc?
Like, is that a person or a small organization
that some combination of governments, WHO, UN needs to put together?
SB: So, first of all, you want science to bubble up at the beginning.
You don't want to have centralized control,
somebody saying, "I know best and I'm going to predict this."
So you want it bubbling up from all over the place,
but then you want a coordinated effort.
The group that is best-placed to do that is the World Health Organization,
maintaining a list of all the different programs that are going on.
We also have other organizations. I mentioned CEPI before.
CEPI has now supported eight different candidates.
I think it's going to support more.
Right now, WHO has on its list 44 candidates,
but some people think as many as double that.
So what you want to do is say, which are the most likely to succeed,
and then put them through some type of standardized set of criteria
to pick a few of them to move forward aggressively for the world.
Obviously, science is going to keep moving,
they're going to keep changing,
and it may be that your original approach isn't right and new ideas may come up,
but you do need to have some process of moving this forward.
And really, that's what I called for.
What we need to make sure is that if companies have adequate resources
to do this on their own,
that's fine,
but if not, they need to be supported by the public sector
and, again, making sure there's adequate manufacturing and ultimately distribution.
Then, after a period of time, we can go back to normal
and return to the normal way vaccines are handled.
But I think that's probably the best way to get there.
CA: How much might this cost, and who should pay for it?
SB: Well, it depends how many cases there are.
The good news is, we're talking now about trillions of dollars in economic loss,
and this is going to be --
CA: I would hardly call that good news.
SB: I mean, I'm making the comparison. Sorry, you're absolutely right, Chris.
I mean, we're talking about tens of billions of dollars here,
not trillions of dollars, and the reason that's important is
you want to make sure that any good idea has its best chance of moving forward,
and we ought to, again, optimize for speed
and not optimize for being cost-effective at this time.
CA: So I guess you're saying that, like,
the rich countries may well be able to afford some kind of vaccine program.
I think what I hear you doing here is representing a lot of the countries
that can't afford it,
and what you're saying is that the world may have to find a way
of spending tens of billions of dollars
to avoid trillions of dollars of economic damage
and all the hardship that goes with it around the world.
Is that about right?
SB: That's absolutely right, but I think the important point is,
this needs to be a global perspective.
I mean, look at what happened with Ebola.
We had a vaccine that was originally made in Canada
by the Public [Health] Agency of Canada.
It was then transferred to a US biotech, then to Merck and Company,
which is obviously a global player based in the US,
and they're manufacturing it in Germany.
That's the way science works,
and these vaccines may need components from other places.
So how do we think about this in a global way and make sure that --
By the way, the second vaccine that's in humans is from China.
Of course, they've had a lot of time to work on it compared to some others.
And they have a candidate that's moving forward.
If that candidate is successful,
we want to make sure that's the one that's scaled up.
And so for me, it's making sure that we're looking at this
as a global ecosystem
with the best candidates moving forward for the good of the world.
CA: Whitney.
WPR: We have a lot of people watching from all over the world
and we're seeing questions,
especially from some of our friends in India who are watching,
connected to this just basically about
how are poor nations going to get access to this vaccine?
And then, specifically, when we think about who gets the vaccine first,
will there be some sort of payment that people are paying for this vaccine
and those who can afford it will get access before others?
SB: Well, the decision on who will pay for it
will ultimately come from the political leaders,
and my recommendation would be, you start off as a global public good,
you make the vaccine available because we're trying to stop the epidemic.
Later on, we can have tiered pricing in different places.
But one of the concerns, of course, is:
Where is the epidemic going to be at that point,
and who needs it first?
I would argue that people that will need it first are probably health workers,
because health workers are going to be on the front lines
and we want them to be there to be able to take care of people.
They're at risk of both contracting it as well as spreading it.
Then you probably want to think about the high-risk individuals,
the elderly, people who have preexisting conditions,
and then eventually, the rest of the population, if it's needed.
So having some type of way of thinking about that.
We'll also need to be thinking about equitable access,
and that is going to mean thinking about the entire world.
Now, Gavi, in the past, including in India,
has worked to make sure these new technologies are there,
but these are vaccines that existed and, in this case, it's a new vaccine.
We have to make sure that it isn't hoarded only in wealthy countries
or in a select set of countries.
And one way to do that would be to have vaccine production in multiple places.
So today a lot of the vaccines that Gavi uses are made around the world.
Some are made in the United States and Europe,
but some are made in South Korea, in India, in China, in other countries.
And so what we could do is have a vaccine transfer the technology and manufacturing
in multiple different sites
so we could have enough vaccine for that original launch.
But whatever happens, there will always be a period of time
when we'll have an exciting vaccine and not enough doses to go around,
and that's when we need to take hard decisions
based upon science on who should get it.
WPR: Thanks for that, Seth. I'll be back later with other questions.
CA: Thanks, Whitney. SB: Thank you.
CA: How confident are you that we'll eventually get one?
I mean, we still don't have a vaccine for HIV,
nor for the common cold.
How can you be confident that we can get one this time?
SB: Well, first of all, as you know, I did a TED Talk even before the one of 2015
talking about HIV and flu and how new science needs to come in,
and frankly, we are making progress
against some of these incredibly difficult organisms.
You talked about variability. That's the problem with HIV.
It's constantly changing, and so you're chasing.
You get a good immune response,
but it's to the strain that was there before,
and now you're chasing new strains.
There are ways to work around that.
It's new science.
I, actually, I am optimistic.
I'm optimistic because we have some experience with SARS vaccines
and with MERS vaccines,
and so people have worked on it.
They've been able to get good immune responses in animals and in people
for those vaccines.
And so we can build on that experience.
I can't tell you how long they'll last for,
how effective they will be.
Will they need to have local mucosal immunity,
which is in the mouth and nose,
as well as serum immunity in the bloodstream?
Will they need to have just antibodies or the other arm of the immune system,
the cellular arm?
These are questions that will need to be answered,
but I am a great believer in the power of science,
and I think in this case the organism is not going to be quite as difficult
as the ones you're talking about that are much more difficult.
CA: You mentioned in your TED Talk five years ago, Seth,
that we've got this situation where we're spending billions of dollars
on nuclear submarines patrolling the oceans
for a possible incoming threat, nuclear war threat or whatever,
and almost nothing on preparation for a pandemic like the one we're suffering.
If the world is adequately shaken up by what's happening now
and gets rational about this,
what is the key structural shift
that would be the pandemic equivalent of having those nuclear submarines?
How do we prepare for a new virus
that we don't know what it will be or when it will come?
How do we prepare to have a much more rapid response?
SB: Well, it's a great question and I think the TED community
has a role to play here.
So first of all, we need better surveillance.
We need surveillance everywhere in the world,
and that's why we don't want to have another outbreak
like in West Africa with Ebola.
You want to have a resilient health system
in every country that reaches out to the periphery.
And that's an important priority.
We're doing pretty good with immunization.
We've reached 90 percent of the kids of the world
with at least one dose of routine vaccine.
That's the best of health interventions.
But we need to reach that last 10 percent and put that health system in place.
Then we need to have a different view.
We need to start working,
where are our likely hot spots?
It's where we're cutting down forest.
It's in urban slums, where there's density of populations.
It's with climate change
and movement of different vectors.
And what we need to do is use predictive science,
and that's where big data can help,
that's where AI can help in terms of trying to do that.
And we need to have a one-health approach,
because we tend to think of animal diseases --
and by the way, people have worked on coronavirus vaccines for animals,
because they also cause disease there --
we need to make sure that the scientists working on veterinary vaccines
are connected to humans, are thinking about those whole ecosystem.
And we need to invest in that.
And unfortunately, after an epidemic, everybody wants to invest,
and they say, "Whatever it takes,"
and then we move to on other things, and investments go down.
What's different about the military is that there is a baseline of investment
that goes on all the time and nobody questions that.
It continues, and that level of preparedness seems to be there.
Bill Gates in his talk in TED, when we did that back-to-back, said,
look, the military are doing war games,
they're constantly testing, they have all this preparatory activities.
Why are we not doing that in diseases?
And, as you know, since then, there has been some war games,
and they've basically said we weren't prepared,
and I think we're seeing now that, in fact,
we're not as prepared as we could be.
So my hope, the silver lining would be that we prepare for the next big outbreak,
because it's absolutely evolutionarily certain
we will continue to have outbreaks.
The question is: How prepared are we to deal with those?
CA: As we wait for a vaccine,
are there other interventions that could be made,
for example, the serum from people who have been infected and have recovered?
SB: So, that technique has been used in other infectious diseases
and throughout history and even in Ebola recently.
That's something that could potentially be done.
Of course, today, it's more attractive if you can make antibodies in the laboratory
and then have those available at scale
and use those,
and I know of a lot of companies that are working on producing those antibodies,
which could be infused in an emergency situation, and do that.
Obviously, drugs may play an important role here.
There's a similar effort to try to create drugs
that are active against this organism,
and if we knew that you'd get sick but there was an effective treatment,
that would also change a little bit of the dynamics
of the fear that exists around this pandemic.
So I think there are lots of interventions.
Of course, traditionally,
a preventive vaccine is the best way to deal with these types of epidemics.
CA: So paint us -- it's the inner optimist in me, begging for something --
paint us the best case scenario, Seth.
Lots of people are saying,
we don't want to be huddled in our homes by ourselves for 18 months,
lovely though the internet is.
What's the best case scenario, putting all the pieces together here?
SB: Well, I think what is likely to happen,
but I don't want to predict, because we're in unprecedented times here.
What's likely to happen is that countries who don't take this seriously
will have severe outbreaks,
those that really take it seriously
and put these extraordinary mechanisms in place
will control the disease.
It'll take some time, it'll take --
you know, this is weeks, maybe months, not years, to do that.
And then you end up with a situation where the disease is controlled,
and you then can go back to life as normal with some cautions around it.
Now there's beginning to be new tests that are going to be home tests.
We're going to be able to figure out whether classrooms, regions,
countries have disease.
We can go back to some level of normalcy,
but one thing that's really important is we can't have areas of the world
with raging disease.
So for example, if people said,
"Oh, we're not worried about Africa, we're only worried about our countries,"
you might end up in a situation where you have large numbers of infections,
the virus is mutating, it's actually adapting to humans.
We saw some of that with SARS.
And then it is easy to reintroduce.
So what you want to do is dampen it down everywhere in the world.
And maybe it'll burn out. Maybe that'll be it.
I personally think we'll probably need a vaccine,
but best case scenario is that those alone will stop the epidemic,
and what we'll need is then a vaccine just in case it comes back,
but of course if I was a betting man,
I'd say let's get a vaccine as soon as possible,
because that's the best way to control a viral infection,
particularly one that is spread respiratorily.
CA: Yeah. It's so interesting what you said there.
Like, the vaccine doesn't know what continent it's on,
what country it's in.
It just does its thing.
SB: That's correct.
CA: So in terms of people listening here,
what kind of psychological advice can you give them?
What should expectations be?
Like, do we have to be ready to settle in for the long haul here,
or should we be looking forward to getting back to business
around about Easter time and celebrating?
SB: Well, again, I don't want to put a time line on it like others do.
What you're going to want to see is that bending of the curve.
I think Bill talked about this.
You want the reproductive rate below one.
You want to get it way below one if you can,
and then to begin to see the disease spread.
And what you don't want to do is, in the middle of that,
jump out and start having parties.
It's not time to go on spring break and start mixing again.
But with careful control,
you can begin to release the controls if that's what science shows us.
And I think the most important thing here is we need the data to tell us that.
That's why testing is so important.
With the wide availability of testing,
we'll be able to keep tabs, know what's happening.
We'll know how many people are asymptomatic, what's happened.
We'll know where there are hot communities,
and we'll be able to deal with this,
is my prediction.
So I don't think this is over a very, very long time,
but I wouldn't rush it during this unprecedented moment.
Otherwise, we're going to end up seeing what we saw in Italy.
What we're seeing in New York right now
is the overwhelming of the health system.
CA: Yeah, no kidding. New York is a scary place right now.
I was out walking today.
I hope that was OK.
But there was no one. There was no one.
Like, you couldn't get within six feet of someone if you tried right now,
on the busiest walk spots.
That was nice to see, but man, it's startling.
SB: I mean, recent data has shown that droplets can spread the disease,
and so people are rightfully being cautious.
And we didn't know that.
You remember when we started, we said it's a point outbreak,
out of Wuhan, wet market,
you had to be in the market to get the disease.
Then it was, if you were with sick people,
you got the disease.
Then it was maybe asymptomatics.
I think as we understand better,
that gives us the tools to do the right thing.
CA: There's a debate out there that seems to be growing again about masks.
The East and West take very different advice on masks.
We were hearing from Gary Liu yesterday that everyone in Hong Kong and China
is basically wearing masks,
and arguably, that has been effective.
The advice in the West against not wearing masks --
how much of that has been driven by just the fact that there's a shortage of masks
and that if anyone needs to wear them, it's medical professionals?
If it's water droplets, it seems like masks could be effective in prevention.
SB: I mean, the most important intervention, as you know,
is some isolation and very careful handwashing or use of sanitizers,
because what happens is, you touch your face --
I forget the number, I think it's like every one to two minutes --
and you touch your eyes,
so if you reach a door handle or you have contact with a surface,
and we know the virus can live on those surfaces,
and then you touch your face,
touch your mouth, touch your nose,
you can spread it.
So the purpose of a mask for a person who is not infected
is not so much to keep them from getting infected.
It is to keep them from touching their face.
So I think what's interesting here is,
how do we get people to have this personal sanitation?
If we have unlimited quantities of masks, people want to do it as a way
to remind themselves not to touch their face.
Now, that's very different if you're infected,
because if you're coughing,
having a mask on does reduce the spread of droplets,
and that's why they recommend it in a situation where somebody is infected
and has to go to the hospital or has to go out and be seen.
CA: Yeah, I was touching my face
all through the Bill Gates interview, apparently,
and I got called to task by our online friends,
which was very nice.
I don't know if I've been doing that today.
It's funny, you're unconscious of it. It's weird.
SB: Yes. No, it's automatic.
And in fact, there was a WHO challenge for safe handwashing,
and I did a video, and I left my water running while I did it,
and my friends in the developing world came to me and said,
you know, I live in Switzerland by a lake where we have a lot of water,
and I wasn't careful, and they were absolutely right.
So it's really good we correct each other,
that's an important point,
and help each other in doing this
to get us to be as compliant as we possibly can for these issues.
Whitney.
WPR: Yep. So feedback online is overwhelmingly positive.
You're really answering all of everyone's questions out there,
and people really appreciate what you're sharing, Seth.
I think one big question is just for folks who are watching from home
and maybe who are not part of your community
in terms of the science community.
How can they contribute to this global response effort?
How can they do something to advance this?
SB: That's a great question.
So first of all, I think it's really important that citizens support leaders
who are following science,
are using science,
because, as you know, sometimes political leaders say,
"Well, I don't want to do this because it's not good for my image
or it's not good for the economy or it's not good for whatever."
And I think you want to have all of your decisions taken by science,
understanding that they're not the best science.
So, citizens need to applaud,
even if it's a tough decision that politicians take for the good
based upon science, that's a good thing.
The second thing that really would be helpful
is this concept: How do we keep our world focused on the fact
that these epidemics will occur?
Another example I didn't answer,
which Chris, when he asked me about what could be done,
we talked about this idea of platform technologies.
These are vaccines that you can test, get them all ready,
and then, when a new organism occurs, you can put it in there
and you know how to manufacture it, how to scale it up.
These types of things can be done. CEPI is trying to do that now.
But the challenge is,
if we, a year after this,
go down to having no money available for these types of issues,
that will be a problem.
So what you need is citizens to say,
"I understand now
that health is precious,
and I want my government, my leaders
to invest in this, in the science,
in the ways of working
so that we will be as safe as we can be going forward."
And I think I can't emphasize enough how important a message that is
for citizens everywhere in the world.
CA: Mmm.
Hey Whitney, stay on as we wrap up here.
I guess what I'd like to give you a chance to do, Seth,
as we wrap this up
is just to look at the camera
and make your call to the world's leaders,
companies,
politicians, scientists, citizens.
How do we move forward?
How would you wrap this up?
SB: So from my perspective,
what we need is the world to come together at this moment,
not to talk about our national programs,
not to talk about our science are the best,
and they may be the best,
but how do we, as a world,
pool our best science, our best resources,
our best ways of working, our best manufacturing,
our best clinical trials,
to move this forward as fast as possible?
The WHO is a global organization whose job is this normative function,
and we can get scientists to help them make sure that the normative function
is as strong as it can be.
We can get the leaders of the world to come together
and put the resources in place.
Given the cost it's having on the economy,
this will be a real bargain to invest in it.
But what we need is to have that mindset of having science drive us
and to make sure that we have no barriers in stopping that science going forward.
That's my request to the world, and I think we can do it,
and if we do that, we will end up seeing the power of science,
which will give us the tools we need
to either stop it -- hopefully, it'll be stopped by then --
but stop it and then prepare us for the next one.
CA: Mmm.
Powerfully said.
I have to say, Seth, it's incredibly encouraging
to know that there are people like you out there in the trenches,
trying to coordinate this immense and crucial effort on behalf of all of us,
and also that there's an organization out there,
that your organization is tasked
to carry any effective vaccine
to the many billions of people who may live in countries
that can't afford to pay the same prices that the West can pay.
That's really cool that you're doing that,
and thank you so much for explaining so clearly to us
what the situation is.
I guess I speak for the majority of people listening
to say all power to you with pulling these threads together.
Thank you, Seth.
WPR: Thank you, Seth.
SB: Thank you, Chris and Whitney and the TED community
for all of your support over the years.
Let's continue to use science and technology
for the good of the world to solve problems like this.
CA: Brilliant, brilliant, brilliant.
WPR: That was wonderful.
I learned so much from this conversation.
It seems like everyone online also really did, which was helpful.
And I'd like to remind everyone that, if you missed part of this interview,
you can watch it on our Facebook page as soon as we finish,
and then also -- and I'm going to read the link --
it's go.ted.com/tedconnects.
So our Facebook page, or go.ted.com/tedconnects.
CA: Thanks so much for joining us.
We get the sense people,
literally all over the world and in so many different circumstances,
and yet, this moment has given us a new excuse
to bring you all together.
Part of me,
even though you really could wish that we weren't in this situation,
it does give us a chance to explore some ideas in greater depth
than we're normally able to, to have these conversations.
These are not 15-minute talks on a red circle.
You can just go a little bit deeper,
and there's something really cool about that
that I think we want to do more of,
and we want to figure out how to hear from you and include you
and make sure that your questions and your thoughts are coming in.
As we speak, we're dreaming up what speakers to bring next.
We know about Friday.
We don't necessarily know beyond that.
But watch this space.
Whitney, talk about what's going to happen tomorrow.
WPR: So we're really excited.
We're going to have Priya Parker on to finish out the week for us.
She is the author of "The Art of Gathering,"
and she's going to give us some really helpful tips, I think,
about how we can stay connected during this time,
which is something I'm sure all of us are struggling with
as we're trying to practice social distancing
and are just spending more time physically apart.
So going into the weekend, that feels like the type of thing
I think all of us can really benefit from hearing.
CA: If you've got value from this conversation,
consider sharing it, sharing those links with people you know.
That would be cool.
And hang in there, everyone.
These are hard days.
We know many people are struggling hugely.
Hang in there. We'll get through it together somehow.
And until tomorrow, take care.
Bye for now.
WPR: Take care, everyone.